this is the mathematical part explaining
what happened in part one i think it's
reasonably simple most people should
follow it but it will make no sense
whatsoever if you haven't seen part one
so i'll include a link to that on the
screen and in the video description
so i actually want to explain this i'm
going to explain this to you because i
think it's pretty cool okay
so first of all what we need to do is we
just need to organize ourselves all
right
so i'm going to i'm going to introduce a
little bit of notation here so the way
we're going to do it is we're going to
go
we're going to do positions x1
x2
x3
x8 x9 okay
and what do we have before so we had
3
2 1
six five
four
nine eight seven
all right so the way we need to kind of
find a way to kind of organize this
because it was a bit haphazard the way
we did it
so the way to think about it the most
successful way is to think about what's
the longest subsequence that ends in
this number
ascending or descending all right so
it's a or d
all right it's better just to actually
get stuck into it to explain
so let's look at now just three right
so what's the longest
subsequence ending in three well it's
just one number
okay so there's one number
for ascending or one number for
descending now if we look at
going looking at left to right three two
so what's the um the longest ascending
subsequence that ends in two well two is
less than three so it's still one
but now we've got two we've got three
two going down there okay so we go 2
making sense so now we go and look for 3
and so 3 again 1 for us ending well 1 is
less than 2 is less than 3 so there's
nothing ascending to it so it's still 1
but now we've got 3 2 1. so that goes
three but we don't have to just do this
in sequence what i want to do is i want
to jump ahead
and look at x
six here all right
so now ascending so what's the longest
subsequence that ends in four that's
ascending so if we go four here
so we're looking at okay what numbers
left of four are less than four well
it's either one two or three it's not
these guys and because these guys
already
they're already uh
in descending order there it means that
we've only got two so we can pick
any one of these to be an ascending
sequence but the point is is that this
is two it could have been that that or
that
but descending
i'm gonna use this in red
we can see that four
well that's greater than all these
numbers so that's not descending but we
do have
six
and five
all right so that is three so
now i can continue filling this out
so this one is two one
two two
three one three two
three
three
so is there anything that you notice
about
this
about these pairs of numbers
each of these pairs are different
they're all different
which is a bit surprising why should
that be the case
and i can actually kind of indicate to
you if i put this in like a
graph now
where i'm graphing against
ascending a descending so we have one
two three four so now if we go if we now
kind of
map this as like a bit of a path you can
see that it goes from one to one
up here to one two see
up here to one three and then it goes
down
up
up
down
up
up right
which is interesting because it goes it
basically fills up all the points here
and that kind of never goes back on
itself so that's an interesting pattern
and there's a reason why if we actually
think about this mathematically we need
to prove this there's a reason why
these pairs of numbers can't be the same
all right so now we're going to prove
that
i'm going to see if i can fit it on this
paper we have to introduce a general
position because we're going to do this
for generality trust me
so we're going to x i could be any of
these right so that has some pair
so it's a i
d i okay
and then we've got another one
xj
which is aj
and dj dj descending so if we replicate
what we did up here we've got an x i
and
somewhere along here we've got an xj and
so now we're looking at
a and d so we can do that again a
and d
and now this is a number and this is a
number all right so we can actually plug
in some numbers it doesn't hurt all
right just remember that they could be
anything because we're doing this in
generality but the point is what if they
were both equal so just like we did
before what we're going to say is okay
so x i
is the
uh what sequence what's the longest
sequence
of ascending uh that ends in x i okay
and this says it's two
so that means there's another number
circled here i don't know what it is
it's not the point doesn't matter
and this one says
three for the longest subsequence of
descending
so that means that this here
is there's there's like
three there's like two things circled
here just like how we did here
but now if we look over here we've got
xj
right
but because all these numbers have to be
different and that was an important
point
there's really there's there's two
things that could happen
x j could either be greater than x i
or less than x i okay
so let's say x j
is greater than x i
all right
which is fine we can assume that
and so now we go okay so if x j is
greater than x i
what's the longest subsequence that ends
in x j
so i know x j is greater than x i
but there's also another green one here
that it's greater than
so i already know it can't be two
it's got to be at least three
but in actual fact it could even be
bigger because there could be other ones
here
that are like greater than x i and less
than x j i don't know
but that's not the point the point is
that this
aj
it has to be greater than 2 right
and then if we think about the other
alternative
we say x i
is greater than x j
okay
now if that was the case well it's
actually the opposite
so what we've got here
is
that around there so now we've got
what's the longest subsequence that ends
in xj
and now we know xj well that's less than
xi and there are another two there
so it can't be three it's got to be at
least four but again it could be
there could be other ones in there we
don't know but that's not the point the
point is
dude it's wrong
so this
is impossible
okay we've proved it
so now what does that mean well what
happens if we add in an x10
right which is zero
so zero is less than every number here
so
it's one
but now we know that we've got nine
eight seven zero or six five four zero
whatever
we know that's four
so we know
here
it has to land
there
and in actual fact we can see that
outside
of this barrier
once we've filled up everything less
than three
it has to be four it has to be four it
has to go four here or four i don't even
doesn't
it could go anywhere to any of these
points but the point is is that it has
to be four because they can't be equal
which is an amazing result it's order
out of chaos
so this is called
the
air dosh zecharish theorem
and if you notice
it's a square
so in actual fact we can generalize up
for any
n squared plus one distinct real numbers
there
is
always
a subsequence
of n plus one
so in this case three plus one is four
and we're dealing with three squared
subsequences and n plus one
uh
that is
ascending or descending
and a remarkable result
and
proven in 1935
which is kind of not that long ago when
you think about it
but it's wonderful because it's order
out of chaos